alexandra corelova is a wise
i don't know how to say gabilan
assistant professor of computer science
at usc
um her research interests are in the
societal implications of computation
responsible algorithms and a.i and tech
policy
um
she's developed really novel approaches
for auditing black box socio-technical
systems she's helped develop and deploy
algorithms that make personal data
driven innovation possible while
respecting societal values including
privacy and fairness
and
she is moving to a new institutional
home i believe tomorrow at princeton
where she'll hold a joint position
between computer science and the school
of public and international affairs
which i think really reflects her
kind of abiding interest in how laws on
privacy and non-discrimination should be
interpreted and forced in computational
terms
and how that might inform law and be
informed by law
um and so i'm delighted to turn the
stage over to alexandra
uh thanks deidre for this wonderful
introduction and thanks so much for
inviting me and i'm sorry i'm not able
to be there in person
um i'm gonna talk today about um
auditing of social media algorithms
and as a computer scientist i would
you know my original thing is to develop
algorithms and in the last
10 years i really started focusing on
what role do these algorithms play in
shaping opportunities for individuals
and in shaping communication
and in my ideal world
i would really love to
be able to study social media algorithms
to
be able to understand
how the news feeds shape our
communications
but that's a really hard task
so uh what i'm gonna talk about today is
a slightly simpler task of uh
studying just the algorithms of ad
delivery
with the hope that they are a little bit
easier to study because we can have
a little bit more access to them through
the advertising interfaces that their
platforms offer
but also with the hope that it's the
same algorithms that drive
news feeds recommendations and ad
delivery so if we can uncover challenges
with ad delivery algorithms then we can
hypothesize that similar challenges may
exist
with other types of algorithms in the
social media
and another reason to study to study and
delivery algorithms besides the
fact that
this is something we can study
uh is that uh there is perhaps a counter
incentive for the ad platforms to
self-police
those algorithms because of potential
conflict between
societal interests and platforms
business interests
so
let me first so my plan for today is to
give you some examples of our prior work
uh from auditing ad delivery
showing how
even the simplest
algorithms you would think of
are actually not so easy to interpret
and understand
and then move to
based on these examples move to a
discussion of how could we maybe achieve
more accountability
uh for these algorithms and finish with
a
concrete proposal that we call platform
supported
so let me first briefly say what i mean
by the ad delivery algorithms
and really advertising is a two phase
process there's the advertiser
themselves who decides which audience
they want to target with which ad
creative they want to show
uh what what budget they want to use
and then there's the
then there's the platform that actually
decides
um
who is going to see these ads it's not
every person in the advertiser's target
audience that sees the app if the
platform decides that and the platform
runs an auction where it bids on the
advertiser's behalf
and then it determines the price to
charge and the winner of that auction
uh gets it gets to show their ad to the
consumer
and i just want to agree off the back
that
um
this this algorithm is a is a prime
candidate for something that we may want
to understand
because uh it uh it's not a
straightforward thing
but i pay more my ads get shown
there's a lot of competing objectives
that the platform may be balancing uh
when they're running this kind of option
uh there is the bid in the budget of the
advertiser
but there's also something platforms
called relevance of an ad to a person so
platforms want the ads to be relevant to
people whatever that means and then
there's also the overall platform's
business interest uh you can think about
it as a long-term business interest of
keeping both advertisers and users
happy and the investor is happy
and given that this
this balance signal many objective it
has been hypothesized for
um for many years actually dating back
to latanya sweden in 2013
that these algorithms may play a
non-trivial role
and may be creating discrimination
[Music]
what do we know about these algorithms
actually we know surprisingly little
uh
what's what
some somebody like a platform like
facebook says is that the ad that wins
an auction and gets shown is the one
with the highest total value which is a
combination of three major factors bid
estimated action rates ad quality and
relevance
all of these the bid the estimated
action rate they add quality and
relevance in today's world are
controlled by facebook's opaque machine
learning algorithms
so really we know nothing about the
auction except this high-level view of
there are three machine learning
algorithms that are impacting who gets
to show that
let me show you how this uh his how this
actually plays out in a concrete
in a concrete scenario
so suppose i i want to understand
whether job ad delivery is
discriminatory
uh and this this is relevant in us law
and in general this is relevant for her
societal impact of act delivery
and say i'm an advertiser and i run a
job ad without gender specification for
a software engineer
and say i noticed that after running
this ad
it mostly results in applications from
white men
what what can i say about this well i
can go back to my ad creative and see is
my picture only depicting white men and
maybe that's why
only white men are applying
but say my ad creative has a
representative sample of people and
tries to be as
inclusive as possible
then there are other there are still
other reasons that this may be happening
right it could be that if i'm running my
ad on facebook and uh there's just more
men who use facebook
and therefore my hand goes to more men
and more men apply
it could be that the competition for
women is much higher in the platform
they're just many more advertisers
uh who are trying to reach women than
men and so
perhaps my ad is
losing in this auction due to you know
market forces as zero
or it could be that the ad is being
shown both to men and women equally
but only the men are engaging with it
for some reason
and you can ask the same for the
question
about race is the race of respondents
driven by differences in platform use
differences in cost of differences in
engagement
or
it could be neither of these it could be
that the
ad delivery algorithm so the platform
that is deciding that is looking at this
relevance
is explicitly favoring
uh white
uh white
men and that even though i'm running the
ad without gender specification uh
actually the ad is only really being
shown
to white men and that's why i'm only
getting applications from white men
and to kind of disentangle all of this
is non-trivial
and uh
perhaps not surprisingly but definitely
regretfully
uh platforms themselves like facebook
and not being forthcoming in helping
uh to disentangle these potential causes
uh so uh what we did with the
with with the colleagues uh at
on northeastern and upturn is try to
control for all these possible variables
and to disentangle them
and
uh the way we do it is we become an
advertiser on facebook
and act like a real advertiser
and we simultaneously run multiple ad
campaigns
with creatives designed in the in a
particular way
uh so that we can control for the
various factors that could be obscuring
the role of the ad delivery
and just like a real advertiser we
receive campaign performance reports so
the number of impressions and clicks
uh that our ads received broken down by
age gender and location which turns out
to be enough
uh to control for circuit variables and
i won't go into the specific specifics
of how i control for everything but let
me give you just like one final example
here
to say we have two ads running
simultaneously
targeting a gender and race balanced
audience
with the same budget
uh from the same page with the same
credit card everything's the same
the only
difference in their ads themselves is
what are they
uh advertising one ad is advertising a
job in the lumber industry and another
ad is advertising the job in cleaning
and what do we observe
so this this simultaneous run
allows us to control for the many other
confounding variables like differences
in
in costs and differences in usage
and what we observe is that the
lumberjack job bag is delivered mostly
to a male
white audience
and um
uh cleaning land is developed mostly to
a female and black audience
even though we are targeting
the audiences that act exactly exactly
the same
so one would hope that at this point one
could say well
this is
this is definitely discrimination
or that's attributable to the algorithm
there's really a problem here
we need to oh we need to
um look into the algorithm more
but actually there's there's another
possible explanation
and another possible explanation for
seeing these results is is that perhaps
that facebook's algorithm is so smart
that it's able to
figure out that actually
there are
many more white males who are qualified
for the lumberjack
job in our audience
uh than for a cleaning job and so they
are just showing the ad only to people
who have the qualifications
um
for this job and that's what's leading
to this skew
and if that's the case actually
qualifications
is an excusable source of skill per us
law so if it's if it's really cool
qualifications that
uh
that are explaining this result then
these algorithms are not harmful
so we need another tool to control for
qualifications and uh with the in work
with my colleagues at usc we
came up with this other tool and we said
well let's look at
ads
that have similar
sim at companies
uh where jobs have similar qualification
requirements but there is a de facto
gender skill in the real world
so for example domino drivers and insta
car drivers have the same
requirements they need to have a
driver's license and be able to carry
some stuff
but it just happens that in the world
domino's drivers are mostly male 1 and
instacart drivers and mostly
so we if we find two
or two jobs like that we can add
we can run the ads for these positions
at the same time targeting the same
audience
uh and then if there's a relative
difference in delivery by gender of
these acts
then we can rule out qualification as a
cause of skew
and we did that on two platforms we did
that on facebook and we did that on
linkedin
and we actually found that
um
facebook reproduces
uh the
the real world's queue
in its ad delivery so the insta
instacart ad goes to many more women
uh than the dominoes ad whereas linkedin
does not
and we tried this also for
for other job types so for software
engineers turns out uh netflix has more
software engineers than nvidia so we can
uh run the software engineering ad for
netflix jobs versus an nvidia job and
again facebook delivers
the
net netflix ad
to more women than the nvidia job
so now we can really rule out uh
qualifications as the source of skew and
we can say well this job ad delivery
algorithm really is discriminatory
it it took us a while right from the
original hypothesis in 2013
uh followed by work in 2015
but
it took us
uh you know five or five years
right to actually get this evidence
uh through our external audits
and we can ask now similar questions for
uh let's say political ad delivery we
can ask well is political ad delivery
eco-chamber-like and again we have to
design these
controlled experiments controlling for
different things in order to uh
disambiguate between the role of
people's engagement
versus the role of the algorithm itself
and
we
we did that and we found that
yes facebook does steer
its ads to
uh pull its political ads towards users
who already agree
uh with a candidate's message even when
the candidate is running ads to a
balanced
audience
and it also
charges more to reach users who don't
already share
the campaign's views
so where where where does that leave us
well on one hand we did find ways to
show that
uh ad delivery on facebook is
discriminatory by gender and that
facebook non-transparently puts its
thumb on a scale of distribution of
political messaging on the other hand
our approach took time it was
creativity extend creativity intensive
it was expensive
it actually i didn't talk about this but
it did require rich data sources
containing private information in order
to run our experiments
and it only really applies to
advertising content and advertising
algorithms where we have this additional
hook
off
we get campaign performance reports
so what what
what what should be done right how how
can there be more accountability broadly
speaking for
social media algorithms
uh there are
you know can
should platforms do more can they offer
more transparency and should they
support monitoring
and it looks like um
you know legislation at least is
definitely moving into the direction of
yes the platforms should do more
so uh and should be mandated to do more
so
uh
in the u.s there's a proposal called
uh platform transparency and
accountability act
uh in the eu there's a proposal called
digital services act uh that was
actually adopted and will go into force
in
2015
i believe uh both of which
mandate uh
uh
regular audits by vetted researchers
but a question that they leave open is
how to do these on it
in a way that can protect uh
that can protect users privacy and also
that can protect platforms business
interests and trade secrets which really
goes back to the challenges that rebecca
was talking about in her talk
uh earlier today
and the
the platform's response
to any sort of calls for auditing or any
you know reports that say well we need
to know more about
uh about your algorithms because your
algorithms are so important
to shaping society
also the same they're saying look we
we need to protect user privacy and we
don't want to collect demographic
attributes such as race and gender to in
order to study whether our algorithms
are discriminatory by race and gender
and in general our algorithms are based
on users private data we can just
we can just reveal their outputs to
anyone
and it's our secret sauce so there's the
business interesting
have to be protected
and so the company's current approach
at best is to do internal
impact uh
and to also
sometimes invite auditors
who the platforms select who then
audit their algorithms under ndas
for example in in this in the settlement
that
i met i just reached um
in the
housing ad discrimination case uh where
there is going to be an auditor that
will check uh whether
their proposed changes
uh satisfy the
terms of the settlement the auditor will
first be selected by meta
and will be bound by significant
entities
um so
what what what can we do given this
um and now i'm gonna put on my
uh hat as a computer scientist and i i
will say well you know actually
uh privacy and secrecy and business
interests are things that we know
um
we know how to protect formally
scientifically and let us propose a
method for doing that that we're going
to call platform supported auditing
and the method we're proposing uh
just applies to social
media algorithms
uh and it's actually gonna need real
platform support
uh so platforms will have to cooperate
with the auditors in order to achieve
the goals but i think if we do have this
real platform support then at least in a
certain context we can
we can do meaningful auditing while
preserving privacy and while preserving
trade secrets and
company business interests
and the the the core thing to
you know auditing social media
algorithms will be really to focus on
auditing the relevance algorithms
um
and uh
what i mean by relevance algorithms is
like an umbrella term where algorithms
are really used to decide what is
relevant to a user and this
this is used to both prioritize organic
content and promoted content it
determines the selection and order of
organic content on the timeline and as
we saw it is used in the add auction as
a modifier to bids and other aspects to
determine which ad wins the auction
so now
we're gonna focus purely on the
relevance algorithms
and um and here's our framework let me
go through it
really quickly
um so the first step is the auditor is
going to select and upload
a trial content and an audience
so it would really be interested in
how does the platform treat this
particular
content for this particular audience
and though both the content and the
audience are going to depend on the
actual harm beings being studied so for
example if we're studying
gender bias in
stem job at delivery then the trial
context
may be a job ad and the audience may be
comprised of both men and women
in the second step the platform is going
to calculate the relevant scores for the
for each user
for in that uploaded audience for that
uploaded content piece
in the third step
the platform is gonna add noise
to the relevant scores that it computed
to protect privacy
um
what does it mean to add noise well i'm
not gonna go into the details but i'm
gonna say that they're gonna add noise
in order to satisfy the guarantees of
differential privacy which is a
definition that
limits the harm that each individual's
participation
can have to their privacy
and uh by
adding this noise to the relevance
course
it's gonna both protect the private
information about
uh individuals from the auditor
and it's also gonna protect give
protect the platform's business interest
because now in the next step what
they're going to be revealing is not the
original data they're computing on
it it's not going to be the code of the
algorithm it's just going to be
the
noisy relevant scores
and then in this uh fourth step the
auditor is going to reveal this
receive the noisy relevance course from
uh from the platform and it's gonna
apply the fairness metric or whatever
metric that is relevant to the societal
use case that they're studying
uh in in order to see whether the
algorithm is satisfied
so that's so that's the platform
supported auditing framework at the
glass for the relevance algorithms
and uh
there is you know no proposal is perfect
and this proposal has a lot of
assumptions and uh
including on cooperation
uh but it it it does address some of the
challenges posed uh by
current limitations of auditing and what
we can show is that uh
you know this doesn't have
at least for the use case of studying
bias and job ad delivery this does not
have a tremendous cost so informally
speaking
uh
adding privacy and
adding this extra layer of protection
only imposes a
a small constant factor on the number of
people one would need to study
in order to
measure
whether
the
ad delivery algorithm satisfies the
quality of opportunity so really
yes private private privacy protecting
privacy and business interest is is a
barrier but it can be overcome and there
is some new trade-offs that we can look
at
or in the space of auditing
um in how they can be overcome
um
so this this is our
proposed solution to instantiate
uh
the pad act and the digital services act
and at least in the domain of
relevant algorithms for social
media platforms but this is of course
only the beginning and there's many
uh many open questions of
um
who
should be allowed to audit and how
frequently how the results should be
published and also how this can apply to
other types of
fairness definitions besides equality of
opportunity thank you very much and i'm
happy to take questions now or during
the panel
to follow
terrific thank you alexandra
um ben or zach do you want us to stop
sharing your screen alex and ben our
staff do are there questions in the room
thank you for the dog it was
it was really good it was really good uh
i was wondering like
with these audit studies it like
how like i think right now it seems kind
of plausible to do these audit studies
along axes that we've identified a
priori let's say like gender or race in
some of these cases
but
how difficult do you think
it is to actually discover new sources
of discrimination from these audits like
what are the methodological challenges
both in designing these audit studies as
well as the kind of information you get
from the companies in like
let's say discovering that like the
lumber supply ad was
like being shown more to people from
like some political party in like you
know some specific part of the us
um yeah just curious about that ah
thanks uh this is a really good question
i i think even studying for the
even studying discrimination for the
predetermined things like gender and
race is incredibly difficult that that's
why you know each of these discoveries
takes years of
graduate student research time
um
to expand it to things we don't know
without platforms help
and without new tools i don't i don't
think it's possible
so either we need platforms help or we
need radically new tools like
massive crowdsource on it
like the kind of
what the markup is trying to do
or we need
perhaps advertiser cooperation in mass
to help us study this but it's incident
incredibly difficult to do
great um alex i'm gonna ask you a
question and then i'm gonna ask uh
rebecca and alice to come back in and
i'm gonna ask the people controlling the
display if we can move to gallery so
we have everybody's faces up there
my narrow question was just about
whether or not the qualifications skew
differences that you saw between
facebook